we're going to have a go at this
question just by doing the arithmetic
first
and then we're going to interpret
visually what's going on and see what
underlying geometry
actually makes this question tick find
the distance absolute value of z
take away w or modulus i said take away
w
between the following pairs of numbers
in the complex plane and then they
provide a couple of pairs
of complex numbers for you we're just
going to have a look at one pair because
it will illustrate what's happening
so if i have a think just numerically
about what's happening
the absolute value of z take away w in
this
context is still straight substitution
right the absolute value of
1 plus 3i take away negative 1
plus i i'm just going to obviously have
to watch out for my double negatives
there
so let's go ahead and expand some
brackets i've got 1 plus 3i hanging out
the front there
plus 1 take away i so
when i evaluate that you're just going
to collect like terms for the 2
and then 3i take away i just gives you
plus 2i
okay so at this point here if you wanted
you could just say well
i'm going to use my formula for the
modulus here the modulus of any complex
number
is the square root of a squared plus b
squared
where there's your a and there's your b
these are the real and imaginary
components we just get that from
pythagoras
so in this context you're going to get
the square root of 2 squared plus 2
squared that's 4
plus 4 that's root 8 which i guess we
could write as 2
root 2. so there's the answer right what
does that mean what's going on there's a
whole bunch of
language in the question like uh this
stuff up here like find the distance
what's going on here
between between pairs of um complex
numbers so
if we actually just put this onto a
diagram we'll be able to see
what's actually happening in a much
clearer way i'm going to suggest that
what we do is we place
z and w and z take away w
let's plot all of them onto this complex
plane and see
what relationships emerge so zed
i think we said is one plus three i so
if i use this scale here let's call this
one two three um which will make this
one i'll need this two as well so
here up in the top right corner this is
going to be
z which is 1 plus 3 i
and then where's w going to go well it's
negative 1 plus
i so it goes off in the opposite
direction horizontally there's my
negative 1
but it still goes upward to plus i so
this is going to be w
which is absolutely don't need to
bracket negative 1
plus i okay so i've got that in place
let me move that a little bit closer so
now how do i
plot the relationship between that and z
take away w
right well z take away w is this guy in
here
2 plus 2 i let's put that in this other
color that i was using before
there is z take away w so you can think
about this in a couple of different ways
right
firstly if you want to think about it
i'll get rid of this in a second but
hopefully it's helpful for now
if this is z over here
and this is
w then what you're doing is z take away
w
is first go to z and then do the
opposite of w now since
w goes to the top left then a negative w
is going to go to the bottom
right so that's why you can see you're
going to get this kind of shape over
here so
you're getting this familiar sort of
parallelogram situation that we were
talking about
in the past however what we're really
interested here is
in moduli right so not so much about
direct directions and that kind of thing
but just
distances between different things so if
i get rid of these guys here
where is the modulus of z take away w
the thing that we just worked out
well it's the distance from there to the
origin
there is the modulus of z take away w
and hopefully seeing this guy here it
connects you to what's happening over
here z take away w is this line here
these are clearly
these are clearly the same like these
lengths are just
going to be identical to each other
right because they are the opposite
sides
of a parallelogram so what you can say
here and this is the visual which
i really want you to think about anytime
you see the absolute value of the module
so something take away something else
it's like this question suggests it's a
distance between two things
so in the same way that this modulus
here is from the origin
this modulus here is between two
different points in this case z
and w i could compare z to any other
point
on the complex plane that i like and z
take away that will be the distance from
here
to that arbitrary point so whenever you
see this
don't just think about crunching the
numbers think about the distance
from z to somewhere else or from w
to somewhere else that's the way you
should visualize what this notation
actually means on the complex plane